hey everyone we're back we're now
sitting down with Jamie Heywood the
founder of PatientsLikeMe thanks for
joining us thank you pleasure to be here
appreciate it thank you it's been a
little while I think we first met at
Adams little gathering yes your and
Adams and knowyour and George slean's
gathering with Hans Le Jeune weighing
out those guys were there that was a lot
of fun and then in David Ewing Duncan
was there and that's when I was first
really getting introduced to the work
that you are passionate about and that
David is now passionate about that you
guys really care about so patients like
me 14 years 14 years I it's let's hit
with it like okay you still call
yourself a start-up I know I the five
hundred thousand patients I don't think
you know but we're still a start-up
though because it's why we wrote a
business plan first business plan it
talked about how you put the patient in
the center of medicine and how you know
their treatment decisions and their
health decisions and the devices they
needed all the things around that would
come to them rather than they go out to
this hostile world and try and seek them
out and you know this if we look at the
original business plan which is maybe
crazy ambitious or maybe we're just slow
we're still only you know half done with
what our original intention was so I
think we're still in start-up mode the
way I'd said but the other fun thing is
you know just about how much time passed
we started building the site the month
Facebook bought the domain Facebook yeah
so Jordan so you know mark has been so
he's not a start-up anymore he's been
you know it's a different curve if your
medicine is harder yeah I think yeah so
that was interesting so the patient at
the center and the tools coming to the
patient yeah I mean you know right now
you know patients hop around from
institution to institution to figure out
who's the specialist for my problem how
do I figure it out and
you know that's not the way world works
any longer food comes to you
rides come to you you know your needs
are met by someone you know digitizing
understanding where you are and bringing
it to you and this is all we love to
bring out the original deck and look at
the diagrams which you know and what
were those things that you thought
should come to the patient well you know
why why does a patient to go see
somebody get a second opinion like why
can't we just digitize all the
information about where you are and
syndicated out and have people bid to
say I have a better solution from you
why want you know this is hole I mean
look and I'm not minimizing the value of
touch and healing and the value of a
physician and guiding a patient but
there is a lot of stuff that's digitized
like you do with tumor profile and you
have you know if you could measure
frailty state if you give measures the
other things that's something where you
could have sort of a competitive data
war to say who's got the best solution
for me and you know helping patients
through those kinds of information
spaces
you commit to okay give me an example
for me is that I've herniated a disc in
my spine and I just remembered that the
only thing that happened was I got one
piece of feedback from one doctor and
then I took the MRI home for myself and
then I was starting to look it up online
trying to figure it out myself right so
why not be able to send that digital
copy of them all right out and get a lot
of different feedbacks an opinion and it
could be cheap I mean like you managed
to spend a hundred dollars and a
radiologist reads it and gives you an
opinion back but that that requires the
infrastructure just sort of digitize a
human being
facials like he's been working in the
phenotypic part of that I think the
other reason it takes so long is you
know maybe I'm an optimist but the
digital technology to actually
understand the biology in you it really
wasn't ready so we built the company to
be a Diagnostics approval a Diagnostics
validation learning platform but there
were no real Diagnostics I mean genetics
as we heard about today it's sort of
this smaller part of the problem of
health the real problem is how are you
where's your immune system you know
where is your metabolites your protein
your you know your RNA all the things
that are going on in you now your
bacteria viruses phage everything
where's that and those technologies are
just emerging to the place where we can
understand and use them
and that's where we're at right in the
center right now yeah you know so and
then initially for about the first eight
years or so it was a lot about
collecting data from patients based on
what they were doing to help themselves
through medical what are your treatments
what are the problems what are your
symptoms you know you say you have
depression I said to management you have
I have no energy and you have this
anxiety so maybe we're not the same so
I'll find someone else that's different
and then you break into groups and yeah
all of our work was sort of that mostly
with pharma that sort of population
analysis and figuring out and then of
course patients got a lot of better care
and what I love is there's hundreds and
hundreds of stories of someone that you
know found that nugget of difference you
know with like you and I we look the
same we're similar like we would
classically do that but the bit
underneath us we are completely unique
we can now measure that uniqueness
what's different about your physiology
my physiology all these are very little
stupid about your phenotype my phenotype
and then that action of that can become
actionable right so something that works
for someone and I have a little ADHD so
so that's something that works for some
of the little aged ADHD may be different
than something that someone is not have
that and so that begins to parse that
out and as we track the loops you know
someone trying something and learning
yeah and then you had biology and then
you had devices and
mhm yeah I imagine the tree as you were
explaining it's awesome and there's
feedback loops that make the efficacy
higher as you go yeah oh you mentioned
the the the sort of dinner we had where
we sort of we're playing around with
what we call a stage and there's like
what's it like to have dinner and what
is it to right so we have the data from
some of that data back we're going to
share it soon and you know there's this
great thing where I can look at it's
more than the dinner now it's hundreds
and hundreds of people but I can look at
that and say you know why do I know for
instance so you know when I get a little
tipsy my my cardiovascular disease risk
goes down slightly but the next day it
goes up so it's sort of like you get to
look at these variables and play it
through and you can you know and but
it's also serious so for instance you
know there's this conversation about
longevity this meaning and should you
take metformin well there's a fair
amount of you know non double-blind
evidence that metformin in a variety of
studies seems to extend life can I look
at that in me so now I can take
metformin in this you know this study
I'm doing it myself
the some of these digital versions of me
and I can look at how metformin changes
my biology and it might be different
than how it changes your biology and we
might be able to find cool it moves in
the direction of making them younger and
then you look at how we measure our age
with the telomeres or or we have an
immune index of age we have different
ways of measuring things so
I mean it's the it's the it's the
nascent beginning but you know I was
there in the beginning of the computer
age and you could sort of feel the
pieces coming together there's this
directional distance to things like
cardiovascular disease or pain or
depression or or you know cancer risk
and they're not accurate they're just
preliminary directly like you like given
two choices you don't want to go that
way you'd rather go that way right and
you know you could be this way it could
be that would but you don't quite know
but then you start to use these and you
start to look at things that you know
make you healthy like you do the Dean
Ornish diet and you do that for a while
David it is an experiment he went on
paleo they went vegan and we look at
what that did to his cardiovascular
disease risk we measure those variables
and then you start to see those things
what happened let me measure what how
well we don't know what happened the
message is this relatively yet so you're
using proxy measures right but but you
know but something like Fitness you can
measure directly or pain or insomnia you
study a lot of right yeah so these
things you have these directional and
you're also pushing this quantify itself
this is a guinea-pig movement right peep
any Pig movement yeah and and that's and
you got to meet people where they are
like some people are sick and they just
want to try them how to get better some
people are trying to optimize themselves
some people are just curious and weird
like me you know and and you have to
meet each person and say well what's the
thing you want to learn some people
don't have the money yet to try and play
around with it well that's we talked
about that today about the cost factor
and I you know and I think you know
there are certain kinds of conditions
and things where it's worth the money no
matter what because the the potential
benefit it's worth the current cost but
you're still pretty high but you know I
own the first PC and then I own the
first IBM 80 and then I own the first X
to go through them all one after another
and and yeah yeah you pick up the iPhone
and you look at your iPhone you say oh
this is more power than my first twin
computers combined right so you
Exponential's are brutal they make cost
go away so I you know I'm thinking about
a world 3 5 years from now or what you
know I spend about maybe four thousand
in my blood every two weeks that might
be five years three hundred it might be
in seven years a hundred yeah tan that
might be 50 it might go down like you
can look at the curls and you get better
knowing what to measure you get better
at measuring it better you just commit
to scale not having to go into an office
to go and get a gun yeah yeah so part of
what we've been doing this year like you
said tools come to you little bit so one
of the ways we're running our own
program where we're working with people
to understand their disease and deliver
information and management services
around them is we just we just said
we'll just send you the phlebotomist you
know you hit a button we make an
appointment they come to you you know
and
we can't begin to forget centrifuges and
cars and a bunch of other fun stuff and
you know those are problems is just gets
solved they get better and better and so
you can just feel the beginning the
revolution interesting you'll send a
phlebotomist to someone's house yes and
that'll be like 250 bucks or something
for its single tester um well there's
lots of variables what's the cost gated
phlebotomist there there's the cost of
shipping the cost of storage whether
you're doing dry ice and there is a it
depends on what you want to do and how
you want to do it I think that that that
yes that is an imaginable price point in
the near future but the other side of it
you know Walgreens and CVS and Walmart's
are starting to have centers and so you
know as as Alex said we're in an uber
world that $250 can go down and then
and suddenly you know but the security
as well is really important to people
right as I want to trust the source did
you get it it was a good brand you had
to do with good people but you know you
know when wouldn't when you took a car
and I used to take a car in San
Francisco ten years ago it cost me 180
bucks to book a car and show up and go
to my hotel and now I show up and I hit
a button and it's separated there well
that's to do right now so which car you
take right and by the way that seventy
dollar car might be there that might be
the phlebotomist come to your house the
other one might be walk to your CVS in
the corner and yeah you know they can
take your phone walk and do this they'll
do it right no wait no lying no charge
all him does it like you know so I think
it's all about creating liquidity to
creating digital understanding of who
you are they're creating liquidity for
anyone that believes they can help you
become who you want to be to reach you
yeah that's what the that's what you go
so as we measure all the biometrics and
we have all these tools coming to us and
they become cheaper they become easier
to access they become more safe private
for me to give the data that is there is
there a specific way that we can
collaborate across like horizontal
marketplaces absol of data absolutely
yeah
Wow how do you envision that and also
how do you envision that globally not
just across corporations but across
countries you know I think the short
answer is just wait and see a little but
but I mean
me and our partners in the digital life
ecosystem with my carbon acts have been
basically working on that problem for
two years and you know it comes down to
common standards common SOPs real
attractive stands are practice standard
practice comes down to relentless cost
attention to come down to commitment to
volume so that you can set up true
infrastructures at the data level it
comes to bringing what are the
meaningful and actionable things to
human beings connecting them to the
proxies that exist in the system like
the existing tests and existing metrics
building data architectures a lot of
that thing and I think part of it's
exciting to me is you know right now the
process of science is define a question
go recruit a CO or choose some
technologies use them differently than
everyone else put it together produce
something that comes to a conclusion
publish the conclusion and the data
because it's done differently than
comparable and there's so much skill in
all those steps that no matter how good
a scientist you are you're going to be
not as good as someone that's an expert
in one of those steps right so I want to
imagine a world where not-too-distant
future where you go to a portal as a
scientist could even be on your phone
I'm doing this now like I read a paper
about something I think is interesting I
send it to the informatics team
and sometimes cuz it still takes effort
they'll take the paper and they take all
the findings in the paper they map those
findings to our digital biology what
they know about me and they say Jamie
this is where you fit against the cohort
of people that we look at in this paper
and so I can we could imagine not too
far away you're just reading the times
about some new study a little widget
says up not about posting on Facebook
where do I fit yeah what's this mean to
me yeah and not in some future
actionable crazy state but like no we go
look up your biology on the paper yeah
and tell you what that means to you at
that moment I'm eating out that's why I
think I like that there's a very
profound linkage coming
and you know and having lived through
the initial age of the computer age when
I went from drafting to CAD you know I
hand wired the first network and my you
know company when I was an engineer a
little jet Jack cables and semi people
don't see revolutions they they say well
this is working and this is working and
this is working and there's new stuff
you have it come you don't do this it
doesn't do this you don't do this and
those little things they all get better
incremental be better and then suddenly
someday there is no old way and no one
is the shift yeah I love that one day
there is no old way right yeah it's
totally true which is actually soon to
be seen with automation as a lot of
service and retail industry jobs which
kind of leads me to a thought that I
just want to hear your perspective on is
what do you think about the
proliferation of wealth inequality and
exacerbated by technology are you
concerned at all about a class-based
speciation
it's it's such a central question so I
think about it in the following way
for so much of time we struggled to be
alive even for so much a time we
struggled for our tribe or our group to
be alive and then and then we started
off so much in time for our nations to
emerge and to get to the place where
there were institutions and then we
reached this golden age where we
struggle for grills and we struggled for
Lexuses and we struggle for you know a
better shirt that can you know pick up
the the pretty person of the whatever
gender you're interested in and we're
all genders are interested in and there
is truth that we live in a profound age
of Plenty and that profound age of
Plenty
it's created a whole new problem I mean
there is the Stratis consumption just
consumption it's that I think there's a
real conversation that has to be had
about what do we want as a species what
do we want to do as individuals what's
our purpose how do we want to decide
right and it's not it's not to I my big
thing about this is that I think as
humans were programmed to think in
decades like mmm I have nine seven year
old eights you know I'm saying I think
about how they work for I want to work
on that but I live in a world driven by
capitalism and thinks and quarters and
and capitals become increasingly
powerful in this new you know
stratification a huge in its then we
along now foundation which is on this
ten thousand years ten thousand but
there's I think the real question is is
you know we are at a moment we have to
engineer the evolution of human culture
to fulfill human purpose and I'm and
right now we've handed it over to
capitalism and I'm not sure I love the
way it's choosing to make us well I
don't think it is they're definitely
aspects of it the incentive for
innovation and creativity I don't know
what there is said in special said I
actually think that the kinds of
problems that myself or george and
others work on that take decades the
capital structure
we compete with things that are just not
that worthy yeah but they might work
quick they they're the the quick cycles
this quarterly cycle things versus the
ones that are really trying to work at
it for the decades or so there's a few
scenes say you know gotta be
sufficiently you say like like I got a
business plan
it's got like 13 years to pay off and
then I still have another 10 years with
the work to get to the point where as in
it like yeah you know and that by the
way a great does my ethics are great
I've realized up and they do better than
our wrestlers we did it truthfully if I
should went along but I don't want
another photo sharing I don't want
another dating app like I know the world
wants to make more money doing that and
that's kind of the shiny object that we
can confuse people with to make them
chase the next thing to make them
anxious to do that I want a world where
my kids aren't worried that the seas are
gonna take out the Logan Airport and
kill the oceans through acid and and I
want a world where you know I can
imagine my son gets to think about how
do we build a culture where people are
fulfilled and using our resources to the
best purpose for our children that's not
the world we live in that's what I want
to see investment in yes I love the
feeling of values driven people and that
seems to be a reoccurring theme within
this group and it seems to be a
recurring theme within identifying
people very quickly in their industries
whether it's the centralization or
neuroscience or AI robotics wherever
they're in biotech and just asking them
straightforward about their values what
do you care about what are you building
into this world and just and just
feeling what they care about do they
care about leaving that world for the
kids so they can design a better
civilization together and
I'm happy that you're bringing this up
with this passion that you have it
really resonates at me
I have a caveat I want to pick an X out
I don't like mr. the mantle of values I
what would you say I think that each of
us through our our birth and our
formation and our experiences our
strengths and weaknesses find a role in
the world where we connect and we
integrate you know it could be it could
be a simple caretaking if you go that's
all
give me a caretaking role which is very
complex role or it could be and I don't
know that I'm doing this for values I'm
doing this because it's what I'm good at
and it's my role and I love doing it and
and so I think there's more selfishness
to it than to say that it's something
I'm doing not it I have the and I get a
lot out of it so III don't know III go
to society maybe I mean the the but I
mean I think but that's again that's
part of what I'm I would hope for more
people to have more of what I have which
is the ability to work mostly on what I
really love doing love yeah yeah yeah
so that's values or principles or a
little bit of selfishness or a little
lot of selflessness building a better
world together Jamie thank you so much
for joining us I really appreciate it
pleasure again thank you